what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch today from new rock stars
marvel's what if episode 6 easter eggs
and breakdown them sharing their
knowledge with us and speaking of
sharing knowledge and skills thank you
to skillshare for sponsoring today's
video
guys if it's your first time on the
internet skillshare is the premiere
online learning community with literally
thousands of courses across countless
subjects to help you develop your
creativity and unlock new skills we
actually just got a new lens so i went
ahead and brushed up on my dslr base
cinematography
you you didn't take the the class i died
with justin bridges fundamentals of dslr
photography course it was a great way
for me to refresh my knowledge of the
basics of exposure you know like
aperture iso and shutter speed things i
know offhand oh yeah did you also learn
about working with dslrs in the studio
setting as well as
outdoors let me check you bet i did john
justin even gave me us tips for editing
framing and choosing the right equipment
and allowed us to submit our work my
work for feedback upon seeing my photo
he told me
greg craig you greg should be teaching
the course wow man it really sounds like
you got a whole lot out of this i did
and you could too john if you took some
time you just applied yourself you sound
like every teacher i've ever had the
first 1 000 people to use our link in
the description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership and after
that it's only around 10 a month for a
continued membership and there's no ads
so you should you know click the link
and uh use the code and then maybe you
know a thing or two about photography
maybe you wouldn't
should go ahead and roll that roll that
intro
[Music]
change your clothes what do you know
let's go welcome back to new rock stars
it's me mt and this is a breakdown of
episode six of what if we're black
panther fans we're gonna watch this wow
no no no
just kidding mt rocks man go watch the
rogue theories and also their instant
reactions for marvel's whatever yeah i
know who you are empty and i love you
buddy why don't you follow me on social
media it hurts my feelings given the
treat of the return of michael b
jordan's killmonger to the mcu in a
scenario where killmonger was the one to
save tony stark in afghanistan rather
than tony being saved by a box of scraps
you know like a normal person but let us
go ahead and get into all those neat
little easter eggs and things that you
could have missed from this iron man ass
black panther crossover episode shall we
my beautiful nerd babies i think we
should and right off the bat we start
off the episode with ua to the watchers
stating every journey has a beginning
and jeffrey writes deeply mysterious
sultry voice that his mama gave him
before we watch the watcher watch over
the very beginnings of our journey
through the mcu through the recreation
of the very same opening shots from iron
man 1 from right before tony stark's
military convoy is attacked in the kunar
province of afghanistan with a few
exceptions here and there like how the
soldier named jimmy who asks tony for a
picture holds up a camera in what if but
in the movie he doesn't grab his camera
until after tony says it's okay and also
how the holes that end up murdering poor
soldier jimmy shortly after are slightly
different than in live action like it
has a different spread and you know i've
got to say it but there is a glaringly
apparent lack of both ac dc's back in
black and references to myspace.com like
we got in the live action movie which is
rude tom was your friend too marvel tom
was your friend too everyone's trying to
do the skedaddle out of the convoy we do
notice that animated tony uses a flip
phone while rdj kept that mother
sidekick fang on him because how else is
he going to replace terence howard
rhodey with don cheadle roadie in his
myspace tough five exactly there's no
other way oh god iron man one is
basically a period piece now and then
this leads us to a major nexus event of
the episode eric killmonger eaten the
missile that would have embedded
shrapnel into tony stark's body forcing
tony to develop a miniaturized arc
reactor and the first iron man suit to
save his own life but i will say though
what i will say though is for pointing
out big detailed differences here in
iron man 1 by the time they get to that
shot of the stark industries missile the
missile would have gone off by the time
killmonger grabbed it with his hand it
would have exploded in his head if we
were following in the same timing of the
device because that did pop up and i'm
like wouldn't that blown off his hand by
now because i remember that opening
scene so well while we're doing a
comparative contrast that's something i
just wanted to contribute to
this when you've already pointed out a
gazillion things i did not notice great
job empty
[Laughter]
killmonger's theme music from the black
panther score plays in the background
while killmonger shoots and murders a
ton of off-screen ten rings terrorists
like this [ __ ] had aimbot installed in
his cranium and i think that these
animated movements could have been an
intentional callback to that time where
everett ross describes killmonger's time
in afghanistan in black panther 1.
joined the seals and went straight to
afghanistan where he wrapped up
confirmed kills like it was a video game
oh yeah yeah
i could see that yeah as he helps him up
because i believe that this shot is
supposed to reflect a spartan handshake
you know to represent the new alliance
bond that these two now have together
and i also really love how we get to see
killmonger say that his name is a
nickname in afghanistan after everett
ross alluded to him getting the nickname
in afghanistan in black panther
that name is like fresh because he just
got it and after the watcher watches the
beginnings of this very unfortunate new
relationship we get animated shots of
the three most iconic moments of tony
stark's journey as a hero in you know
the good universe the forging of the
first iron man mask in the cave the
formation of the avengers in new york
and finally his final sacrifice in
avengers end game and i especially love
how when huatu says the word forge that
we do get the shot of animated tony
forging his suit however in this
instance when he's banging on the box of
scrappy masks in what if i did notice
that tony's box of scrappy reactor in
his chest glows a lot brighter and wider
than robert downey jr's more subtle
reactor in the movie and also this
animated tony doesn't seem to have the
glow of a fire source coming from the
right side of the frame like rdj does in
the movie and also while the iconic
avengers pan from the movie of course
starts off with hulk screaming at us at
the camera in avengers one here we see
it start with iron man before the hulk
screams so like we kind of get like a
couple of seconds before that iconic
shot which is right
and also also when animated end games
but anyways moving on when tony begins
his press conference he notes that the
drink that he was holding a convoy was
actually a macallan whiskey from the
year 1926 a bottle of which in the real
world recently sold for a whopping
1.2 million dollars so yeah i would be
kind of upset too just one glass of that
alcohol juice is worth more than my
entire life but anyways
a job that was originally given to happy
hogan in our timeline in iron man 3
which is why we see an unhappy hogan
here christine everhart the very same
reporter that tony stark spends a night
with at the very beginning of the first
iron man film is the one to ask what
exactly eric killmonger was doing in
afghanistan in the first place with
actress leslie bibb reprising her role
as christine you know they need to give
leslie bib more credit she keeps popping
up in the mcu she's one of the most
reoccurring characters when you think
about it she's been in quite a bit and i
feel like there's still a lot of people
who don't even know the character name
of christine palmer
i do because i'm a real nut unlike all
you fake fans out there you fake fans
christine palmer rachel mcadams who did
i say
you said christine palmer
you fake fans
that was a test and y'all failed oh
failed you guys failed received everhart
it stays in the video no retakes
even though i control the edit of this
video
but not reprising their role for this
episode is jeff bridges as obadisha
stain with the voice actor kif van duvel
doing a pretty damn good impression
instead like he does a fantastic job at
capturing the exaggerated swagger of a
greedy corporate executive who just got
caught trying to assassinate the head of
a major weapons company that jeff
bridges just perfected in that role like
that exaggerated swagger just hard to
replicate with a box of scraps you know
who would have been perfect rosbar quan
who also plays red skull now and he
played red skull in what if episode one
but he does it excellent jeff bridges i
just like realized that you slide your
jaw over like it is and there he is man
just get him in every one of them well
that's the thing you can't have him
hoarding all the
rolls yeah that wasn't good commentary
cut that cut that greg
not now and i freaking love this monger
match up here with the killmonger having
taken down the iron monger by dropping
olive stains tan rings tea online black
widow style you know because black widow
did that at the end of winter soldier
like about
team eric procured during his time
undercover in the 10 rings in all of
this while the heartbeat-like thud of
ludwig granson's killmonger theme plays
in the background yet again and i
literally cannot get enough of that [ __ ]
because ludwig granson is the man son
but anyways
it was not an appropriate sex joke about
maxim models coming for the king on
thedisneyman.com
tony stark offers killmonger
yeah mine too
pepper in iron man 2 and says you me
will be like butch and sundance which is
of course a reference to the movie butch
cassidy and the sundance kid starring
hydra's very own black shirt she's like
another instance in the mcu where tony
stark mentions a movie where a co-star
of his also started you know like that
time tony stark mentioned the big
lebowski in the end game and all this
then leads us to seeing pepper have a
chat with don cheadle's james rhode
marking the second time what if has
inserted an mcu recast into their acting
predecessor's mcu time period with the
first instance being oh
i feel like that would be wonderfully
awkward that would be amazingly awkward
somebody made a poster online of terence
howard's likeness in the war machine
suit and it was like what if terence
howard secured the bag oh man it was
like yeah i kind of want to see that
that flew over my head did you notice
you didn't point out i didn't point it
out you didn't point out so how do we
know you're telling the truth right now
i could be lying not that i don't think
about terence howard every day though
every single time i see don cheadle and
anything
there's our justice parents and later
when tony and killmonger hang out in
tony's iron man 1 garage killmonger
picks up a portable version of the
jericho missile that tony stark was
apparently working on even before he
originally demonstrated the real thing
in afghanistan and like the design of it
kind of reminds me of how shield
miniaturized the asgardian destroyer
armor in avengers 1. you know the same
gun that coulson shoots loki with before
he dies like a badass
shooting an asgardian [ __ ] and then
shortly after killmonger quotes howard
stark's lying that's right peace means
having a bigger stick than the other guy
my old man had a philosophy peace means
having a bigger stick than the other guy
and when eric tells tony that his dad
was killed by gang violence we already
know that michael b lyon
murdered by king t'chaka and black
panther won and killmonger knew that his
father was murdered by panther claws i
found my daddy with panther claws in his
chest and also can we please talk about
how tony already had access to mit's
doctoral thesis database when pulling up
killmonger's plans for the liberator mix
because this definitely feels like both
a reference to tony stark's affinity for
mit that we see in civil war but it also
makes me feel that maybe just maybe
we'll find out that tony stark was well
aware of riwi williams genius before he
passed away in endgame when we see riri
at mit
forever and picturesque series i'm
starting to get this weird vibe that
has been loving for protege this entire
time which is why he's so readily
accepting killmonger as his like
pseudo-son because peter parker at this
age he's just a young boy like we
haven't seen him yet in iron man 2 about
to get shot by those hammer drops i
actually really do like that idea of
tony stark has i mean it seems like it's
already been planted in here already but
he has been looking for a protege to a
certain extent but it would just make
for a better transition when it comes to
iron heart i mean i don't think robert
daddy would return for a cameo but you
know there'd probably be something of he
left behind some message as don cheadle
talks to him yeah there's something he
left that suggests his presence but he
doesn't have to show up to actually sell
yeah
but yeah that would be a cool detail
like okay like and that'll lend credence
to spider-man homecoming and all that
stuff too i think that's a cool idea but
anyways moving on this anime gundam
inspired design of eric's wakanda
liberating liberators was 100 inspired
by actor michael b jordan's deep love
for the anime medium you know much like
the design for killmonger's entire
outfit in black panther was revealed to
have been designed with vegeta from
dragon ball z
oh
akin to the montage that we get in iron
man 1 when tony was first building his
mark ii armor you know this must be so
cool for michael b jordan if he is that
big of an anime fan it must be so
awesome for him for his like mcu
character to get this animated treatment
i know it's not the same as anime but
still it's pretty cool to go into the
animated format with that you know he
brings anime creatures or machinery into
the mcu this vo work was awesome in here
vo stands for voice over work i know a
lot of you guys might not know that due
to your limited capacity of knowledge
but i'm here to educate you and give you
the better details that you might not
know most people will get that sarcasm
those who don't know what vo stands for
will feel offended as you should tv
wiring nano circuitry and bloody mary's
hangover's starting to kick in which
kind of makes you see the wonders being
a hero has done for robert downey jr's
tony's alcoholism problem which is of
course something the character has
historically struggled with a lot more
in the comics but in this universe tony
seems to drink a lot more than we ever
see him drink in the mcu like he
literally drops a glass of whiskey as
he's dying but anyways while tony and
eric are thinking of power sources for
the mex eventually deciding on vibranium
much like ultron did in age of ultron
with his vibranium core for sokovia it
kinda reminds me of that shot of tony
nat and bruce planning the new york time
heist together now is also cracking up
when tony almost had the idea for a mini
arc reactor if we could miniaturize an
arc reactor
oh that's a dumb idea but anyways tony
eventually recruits the help of ulysses
claw the notorious black panther villain
with a killer sound system for an arm
that was originally introduced in angel
ultra and that's when tony says that he
met claw at a weapons conference in the
past where he found out about claw's
interest in this hot new african rock
that all the kids are talking about it's
to be all the rage so 2008 tony reaching
out the club makes a lot of sense and
also the office where the free talk
about claw is a recreation of tony's
office from iron man 1 which is pretty
fun but anyways when roadie meets up
with claw to make a deal at claws same
south african salvage shipyard from age
of ultron club managed to procure a
steer from one of wakanda's dora melange
which apparently are worth 10 million
dollars a pop so needless to say johnny
mayonnaise experienced the world's most
expensive ass beating in falcon in the
winter soldier god damn 10 million
dollars is pretty low all things
considered i know
how did that bottle of alcohol they
mentioned it was a 1.2 really i don't
know so it's 10 of those bottles because
you've got to probably kill adorama
melanche in order to get this here the
first place would seem like a way bigger
than a 10 million dollar job to begin
with be like 100 million
yeah i would expect it to be a lot more
money especially considering how like it
literally takes out the gundam that yeah
they like seem like they have infinite
uses against yeah organic machine
anything you can melt it down and turn
it into other stuff like yeah it's the
most valuable resource on earth but
anyway speaking of ass beatings t'challa
of course gave a whole helping to claws
unfortunate partners in crime from the
shadows hearkening back to that initial
stealth scene of t'challa stalking that
convoy in the jungle in black panther
but unfortunately you can see what's
going on
both him and his mcu brother were killed
by the hand of another mcu brother a
hand that was holding a new version of
the stark industries sonic taser that if
you remember from iron man 1 was used by
obadiah stain on more than one occasion
like i'm actually starting to wonder if
ulysses claws arm in the mcu is based
off of this sonic taser technology and
also t'challa dying by the hands of a
sonic weapon at claws place is
definitely an illusion towards
t'challa's many dealings with the sonic
powered claw in the comics because in
the comics claw is essentially black
panther's joker like that is his nemesis
but anyways moving on when t'challa's
body is being discorded by the dora
milaje her words wakanda forever can be
seen written on his casket in the native
wakandan language which of course serves
as a soft tribute to the late chadwick
boseman but anyways when tony is
confronting killmonger about the murder
of his best friend rhodey he pulls up a
holographic model of the murder scene if
you remember tony also does this in iron
man 3 when he recreates the sights of
all the mandarin bombings to play
detective but something i find really
interesting after eric kills tony is the
relationship between killmonger and
general ross because it kind of seems to
mirror the relationship that t'challa
had with his military ross because he
had everyone oh yeah
so many wakandan shenanigans to be done
with a white ross let me tell you grab a
white roster anyways
is that he's been working with the
wakandan this entire time the same
oconons that he thinks are savages
savages and this is a lot like he did in
the movie which i thought was a nice
touch you savages didn't deserve it
however unlike the movie this killmonger
reveals his wakandan lip tattoo outside
as he approaches wakanda whereas in the
movie we don't get to see that michael b
bottom lip until eric kills claw but
anyway shortly after this we find out
the badass black panther fact that
angela bassett's queen ramonda was a
freaking general of the wakandan army
which makes a lot of sense considering
that the wakandan army is pretty much
female dominated and i very much love
how both the king and queen of wakanda
aren't afraid to get their hands dirty
when they have to like they're kind of
like especially that way and when
killmonger's liberators finally breach
through wakanda's barriers to liberate
wakanda from eric's family we get to see
the world's reaction to discovering the
true opulence of wakanda for the very
first time through the eyes of general
ross undoubtedly giving this universe's
wakanda even more geopolitical enemies
because everyone wants that sweet ass
vibranium and no one's gonna like
finding out that this african nation is
the most powerful and most
technologically advanced nation in the
world and after that
battle that ends with yet another subtle
tearful tribute to t'challa and chadwick
boseman by queen ramonda we have
killmonger and t'chaka enjoying a
wakandan sunset together in the same way
that him and t'challa did in black
panther but this time with killmonger on
his feet in victory rather than on his
knees in defeat and there he would of
course trick his uncle into making him
the next black panther but instead of
seeing his father in the ancestral plane
killmonger has a contentious
conversation with his cousin t'challa
instead and man i don't know about you
but seeing chadwick boseman as a panther
on that panther tree hit me where i live
man because it's really wild to think
that chadwick recorded this scene while
going through all of that pain that he
was going through himself so rest in
peace chadwick postman we really
appreciate everything that you've done
and of course the episode ends with
jerry and pepper the only smart people
a bunch of tony's crazy powerful jericho
missiles at wakanda i'm not sure what's
gonna happen next but it's for sure
going to be some messy [ __ ] though i do
secretly hope that shuri and pepper team
up to make wakandan iron man suits
because let's be real making an iron man
suit kind of science fair-ass [ __ ] for
sure and iron man suits do not exist in
this universe so it'd be really cool to
see shuri come up with the idea for the
iron man concept this is something that
i really liked about this episode a lot
of people have been saying that they
think this one's kind of pointless
because they they expected killmonger to
have a character change or something
because they're dealing with an
alternate universe take i really like
the fact that this is pretty much
killbonger starting his plan just like
15 movies earlier
yeah you know so preventing ironman from
happening so then the sokovia court
situation probably wouldn't arise that's
something that ireman himself championed
that event led to the death of t'chaka
so there's a lot of change of events but
what's interesting here is that you know
shield is still around so you can still
have the possibility of thor showing up
you could still have the possibility of
captain america obviously coming into
the fold bruce banner like all these
other players who can probably take on
black panther
the new one you know the killmonger
version but we don't get any alluding to
that that they still exist for coming to
the freight because it's all taking
place over the course of
you know iron man one's timeline and uh
you know general ross is not being
caught up with bruce banner
being caught up here yeah no yes it's
just gonna be shuri and pepper and
they're gonna be the new saviors of the
world none of those other heroes are
gonna arise at all anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] but most importantly please follow
new rockstars on twitter and youtube and
when you do on youtube make sure to hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a video
please go to newrockstarsmerch.com to
pick up our really awesome shirts like
the shanxi mora shirt that everyone is
really digging everyone's really loving
it so pick one up today before it
disappears forever all right thank you
so much for watching and i will see you
guys later goodbye
the whole reason morris exists just to
sell
you guys are capitalizing on all the
right stuff guys subscribe to new
rockstars you haven't done so already
empty amazing job as always glad to see
you taking over the breakdown for this
one my friend or
are we friends so don't follow me on
social media wow empty how could you
doors wide open buddy
[Music]
lodge the door
we got in the video hey
thanks to who sponsored this video it's
a skill share thanks get your membership
and um hey
we're done